oh that's not supposed to happen I'm
burning my dough
welcome to scrambles where each week
I'll be inviting some of the biggest
taste makers into my kitchen to make one
of the most iconic dishes scrambled eggs
and today trust me it is definitely a
case of Beauty and the Beast as my guest
is not only a former Miss Universe she's
an entrepreneur a designer and she's
just been named number one on Maxim's
Hot List 100 please welcome the amazing
Olivia culpo
hi good to see you good to see you it's
so nice having a foodie here well you
know I'm just trying to keep up with you
I don't know how great my dish is gonna
be we'll find out in a minute
who grows up in the family because mum
and dad have a restaurant I own a
restaurant with my dad in Rhode Island I
grew up in restaurants my whole life my
dad is an entrepreneur in New England
and I am a big foodie and I'm also a
huge fan of yours I know exactly how you
made your scrambled eggs
I'm not going to scramble eggs today
because I can't handle that pressure
right I'm not gonna tell you anything
else though okay so you gonna do an
Italian theme breakfast yes which is
gonna be made up of a breakfast PITA
how are you practicing I know you look
like you have I haven't I didn't write
my own pizza pan though stop it look at
you go go I tried I tried to be prepared
so would you reckon 15 20 minutes are
you ready I don't know anything you need
help help now you know I'm very
competitive
right I'd heard yes which you know
coming from that background you have a
competitive edge as well right yeah I
like to thicken might stay in my lane
right which is super cool yeah oh no no
you're just on that that's okay it's the
wrong chef I like you get started on
your dough so that I can copy you yeah
well I'm watching closely first of all
congratulations on the born maxing font
list amazing yeah I
what happens next year when you go back
into that for a next year we go back
down to number two number three can you
reapply a next year or not I don't know
can I reapply next year can you can love
that I have foods that you love
indulging in what would that be
ice cream hands-down ice cream a career
I know yeah what's your favorite ice
cream brand are you really allowed to
ask you that I would say it would be
like a salted caramel ice cream
breakfast unfortunately it's your food
it smells good so breakfast for me is my
favorite meal because it has a lot of
different things first of all I think
that you can do a lot of different types
of dishes I'm a big color person I love
the color fruit love eggs
yes I've never made my eggs like you
make your eggs because I actually don't
really like custard I like to the frying
pan I know you do yours my sauce I love
the fact you're cooling my food with I
love that who's the master chef at home
was that mom was that dad was that you
definitely my mom right
my mom is your biggest fans bless it was
Lady Susan Susan Susan I love you what's
so special about is it lasagna how's
that bacon doing ah not as well as what
you're doing it's going well I always
start that off to the olive oil helps
render the fat down quickly whether way
you know that's really yeah and also
stops the bacon we're going to Kris
please I mean smart move I know if you
did that backs them but yeah good good
move you're quick super quick you
managed now is it true you made your own
time yes so in Rhode Island there's a
really big
Italian population so huge I mean you
you get the best Italian bread and fresh
dough so I've never really ever I did we
didn't grow up making her own dough
basically rice now I grew up as I tell
it to chalice how cool was that how old
were you first cool my mom plays the
viola so and my mom and dad actually
both met in Orchestra yeah but then my
dad had five kids and he realized that
he couldn't afford just basically us so
he got into the restaurant business and
he really worked his way up from the
bottom and now he owns about six places
and we owned one together in Rhode
Island called the back forty love that
New England oh this is the moment I
cannot wait to try right um so the
secret of great eggs
okay he's making sure you take them on
off the heat okay yeah so we start on
and off that's exactly right at the very
end I'm a massive massive massive
massive fan of Boston right don't you
think the food in Boston is so good
I love it the only thing that I get sort
of slightly angst about oh my god those
winters are Brussels oh yeah it's
terrible
let's see other crap that is doing well
oh my god it's getting there girl Oh see
you're already in front and I'm Way
behind I am gonna need your help with
something right what would that be I
need you to show me the correct way to
cut an avocado cut yeah absolute I'll
show that in 30 seconds that's gonna go
in there I've never made this before by
the way I'm sort of you manage I
probably should have done it like over
here now
what TV use on that cuz I had last night
you stopped telling the cheese cheese I
was gonna do Monterey Jack and then I
decide
to do mozzarella love that thank you and
then I'm gonna talk about with some
parmesan love it and once you show me
how to cut it
I'm favorite food in cities anywhere in
the world what's been your most favorite
indulgence I love what's your favorite
type of Indian number one especially in
the UK because what's the most amazing
Indian recipe know that Japanese I love
I'd never put humble egg on a pizza
dough by the way Joe are you sure this
is gonna work no I was thinking that it
was in oh oh she did it on purpose
gotcha you got it you quick girl Jesus
man that was good
are you finished already so you have
sort of yes so now you're quick are you
finished now is that it done I was gonna
ask you to show me how to kind of akkad
oh but then I saw what you did to your
pizza now here we go I've got you I've
got you so the best way is this way down
through okay and then you gives you just
a little twist like that and then from
there yes
nicely carefully and then I'll take our
little we're spoon and then from there
just go in start at the end there there
you go you traced on top of that
gorgeous I've never put scrambled eggs I
live it on a pizza you know that I've
got some sort of Pollock's some
asparagus mushrooms shots
and it's sort of almost like a sort of
Nicoise finish on top good madam are you
ready no and there you go eh Olivia
culpo inspired scrambled egg pizza done
I'm almost done
madama down take your time please we hit
on Sunday take your time
side by side good girl well done great
job ce soir see you thank you
so yeah great color on the crust dad
will be impressed right
I love the egg yolk already I love the
bacon bits have a card oh I love those
scrambled eggs because I already tried
them it was really good
okay can I have the rest I'm too good
pizzas and it clearly runs in your
family
yeah trust me the big question is and
which pizza do you think is the best who
is the winner I think it's a tie
seriously yes you are the winner and as
your prize I'm gonna mess up your hair
and you have the valve okay if I will be
that way stop champion 2019 whoo weh-weh
by that I like that's like why the Queen
does you just flick them off and then
maybe a little speech no mum I want to
say thank you for those amazing jeans
look we've done to my face thank you
kids Thank You Olivia and a big package
of bobby flay sign that contact dude for
that charity gig cuz I'm going to kick
your yeah thank you you were amazing I
was just trying to keep that no
seriously a great job and big things
that loomed out as well because you are
clearly in the zone girl thank you well
done good job thank you so much for
watching scrambled now check out the
recipes in the description below and
leave a comment on whose egg dishes you
prefer now maybe you can try them
yourself and send me the picture but do
not forget to subscribe to all the
episodes on scrambled god bless great
job girl thank you amazing